unas papas fritas crujientes aún son las
preferidas de los belgas a pesar del
incremento de los precios
y es emocionalmente muy difícil aceptar
que lo que es tan personal para un belga
sus papas fritas vaya a subir de precio
y de todos modos si subió un 10 o un 20%
sigues teniendo una comida por digamos
tres euros y sigue siendo asequible
las papas tanto crudas como fritas hacen
parte de los productos básicos de las
canastas belgas pero la sequía que
afecta a alemania francia países bajos y
bélgica lugares donde más se cosechan
podría ocasionar que la producción en la
unión europea llegue a su nivel más bajo
registrado según los analistas the world
botero markets también el elevado costo
del aceite de cocina y la energía sumado
a las tasas de inflación han subido en
los precios
creo que en 2022 ya hemos tenido una o
dos subidas de precios
si de diez o veinte céntimos por un
cucurucho lo que hace entre 20 y 30
céntimos en menos de un año que es
bastante no estamos acostumbrados a ese
tipo de subidas de precios
sin cruces en el conocido kiosco mesón
antoine donde venden el preciado
producto en bruselas el aumento del
valor no parece afectar a los clientes
las papas fritas son un alimento de
placer que no comemos todos los días así
que si puede que los precios hayan
subido pero eso no nos impedirá
disfrutar de ellas
realmente no consumo papas fritas a
menudo así que para mí es como un extra
no creo que tenga un gran impacto pero
con el resto de los precios si estoy
totalmente de acuerdo que es horrible
pero no sé si podemos influir de alguna
manera
las papas que se cosecharán este año
serán de menor tamaño algo que los
consumidores no deberán sufrir los
tradicionales conos contendrán más
patatas fritas que los actuales